[Music]
haven't seen you with this look this
this rough it looks good it's pretty
sexy yeah if you do say so yourself wife
loves it she does yeah so I am just
going with it forever this is the new
Steve Brown as your wife says anything
that she likes it's like all right I'll
do that
I'm on board the minute she likes it
you're gonna do it for the rest of your
life until she hates it yeah that's what
happened with my beard I was like this
is okay for a while and then one day
it's gone yeah it had to go but just
look see you look very good all right
yeah you have a congratulations are in
order happy birthday your birthday's
coming up pretty soon today's the 16th
yeah 16th yes this is a big one this is
a big big birth this is a big birthday
yeah yeah I'm gonna tell us 50 years old
50 years old yeah how you feeling about
it
how do you how do you feel they're not
it's really only my body in my mind that
feel 50 what's I'm happy it's good every
single problem right you know that up
about your age exactly people
complaining about it I'm all shut up
that's how you talk to old people yeah
sort of affect an old voice yeah your
old shut up you that's yeah I'm not very
nice heard you were but you you're not
nice
are you have plans what you gonna do for
this birthday I would think you'd do
something nice on this one my wife is
taking me away somewhere I don't know
she's probably going to take me to at
the top of a mountain and leave me there
I don't know that's really so that's a
lot of pressure you don't know I've
never done anything like that no idea
I've never have you ever done anything
like that like let someone take you
someplace you don't know where you're
going no I never have I'm actually
really excited about it you know pack
your bag and we're going away for a few
days right I don't I don't know what to
expect what if it's you know Cleveland
you know I know it could be
would be really terrible hey honey love
it here it's so humid all right I got to
ask you something what when since the
since you first started coming on this
show this is I'm talking 40 years ago
yeah when you first started when we were
just mostly a radio show and you would
come on but you would do characters for
us that that were really fun silly
characters a lot of times we just make
these up on this sometimes on the spur
of the moment but one was what was the
German guys what is it German Germans
German that says nice things right the
one I can remember is let's all pile
into the minivan
and get some frozen yogurt
[Applause]
it's really funny it was really great
and then I thought like are you working
on any new characters I haven't I
honestly haven't been working on any new
characters okay cuz you know you're busy
your big film star now I was wondering
you know who you are you've got other
things to do it's true
I was wondering a fight you're a great
improviser what if I just threw some
ideas at you is that something you'd
want to try Reggie absolutely you don't
know you don't know I will try yeah I
will try to invent a character on the
spot okay I have not heard these words
easy has no idea so if you don't like
one you can just say pass no I'm gonna
like them all right use the German guy
you're yelling at no no I'm just getting
into it okay a an unromantic frenchman
you smell like cheese that's terrible i
like it a lobster fisherman calling 911
[Laughter]
any difference at all who doesn't wear
glasses asking a lot of fishermen
calling 9-1-1 yeah alright hey I'm out
on a boat and a lobster's got all he's
got I'm Regis Philbin
the lobsters got ahold of the leg this
is not a crank call
yeah I like that one more let's see this
you leave the glasses on yes we're uh
let's do the shy mobster hey yo so um I
don't know I was thinking I'd maybe kill
ya
[Applause]